ray Ratto bay area legend remember the
media how's uh how's your sports seasons
going out there ray well let's see two
basketball teams have combined for one
win hockey teams in the toilet the
two-foot the two college football teams
are well on their way to going six and
six and then there's the 49ers who are
probably a couple of injuries away from
joining the pack
these a Steph Curry injury what were
your expectations with a healthy Steph
Curry in the lineup maybe 40 I mean I
and that dropped a lot and as Steve Kerr
gave the more realistic prognosis on
klay Thompson just because you cannot
lose that much talent and not feel it
materially well now when you include you
know curry and the injuries active on
Looney they've lost the first second
third fifth sixth seventh and eighth
most important players that's sitting
out the herd right now I'd say they're
25 could this be a good thing I can't
see how look the Warriors had a magical
run and it was a long run I mean when
you count the two playoff appearances
before they won their first championship
and they started establishing sort of
this new method of basketball you know
with with players who could play it
better than anybody else
that's a level of playing with the
casinos money that is not quite
unprecedented but damn close to it and
the fact that it unraveled so fast and
so comprehensively means that they have
way too many places to fix now because
draymond Green will play till he drops
but you know he you know there there are
miles on him and there are miles on that
on curry as well
and it's not the fact that he broke his
hand but they played a lot of games and
they played a lot of minutes and when
they come back you know they're still
going to be joining a very incomplete
team and and I think if it's not a
full-on rebuild they're going to be
scrambling for a while I just think that
you know the worst possible combination
of things happened and they've been
happening since the start of June I mean
it's almost as if they they went to they
went to the Cleveland Cavaliers and said
tell us how you want the Warriors to be
destroyed since they kicked your ass so
many times and that's how it happened I
mean the only guy who's escaped is green
so yeah I think that I think this is
problematic it's going to be problematic
for a while and I don't know if one
draft choice or two draft choices can
change that yeah I'm just curious about
this team when they got D'Angelo Russell
and I remember having somebody on and
maybe it was mark Stein and he said yeah
they're just gonna have him and then
trade him eventually do you think
D'Angelo Russell is is there for the
short haul or long haul until last night
I thought they were inclined to have him
there for the long haul now I wonder
because among other things you know they
are they are cap strapped and seriously
I mean they are up against a hard cap
and to the extent that you know for I
mean it depends on how long curry is out
but I think they have to look upon this
as now a fully lost year and so how do
you not how do you fix that well one
thing is you start to get some some cap
relief because that's when that's where
this starts I mean it just it's they
couldn't really fix losing thompson and
durant to start with and russell was
sort of the interesting fallback for a
team that still had thoughts that
thompson could be there near the end of
the regular season they could make a
playoff right yeah now I don't know how
they do that
I mean I just look at it and go as
dumpster fires go this one this one's
pretty bright and pretty big he's ray
Ratto Bay Area's sports writer what's
your biggest question with your 49ers
who were in action tonight against the
Cardinals the question about tonight is
whether they can hold a team two minus
points because that's who they are now
they are they are a defense and running
game team which is sort of the
antithesis of what everybody has always
looked the 49ers as being but that's who
they are and so I don't know how Houston
our our Arizona fixes that bake because
they're just not they're not good enough
yet and I think there are tests coming
for the 49ers but they're going to be by
teams who do what they do which is keep
possession of the ball keep their
defense off because the defense is only
on like 25 minutes a game that's that's
the big that's the big hidden secret
about this team isn't they have a great
defense that they don't have to lean on
because they run the ball so well and
keep possession for so long so I'm
thinking you won't you won't get a real
sense of them tonight but as their
schedule starts to get more interesting
you might see some teams that can figure
out a way around this and once you get
to the postseason and they run into
teams that are like them like say New
Orleans Seattle I mean just that's when
you're gonna find out the difference
between a great team in October and a
great team in January where are you with
the Garoppolo confidence meter he's
doing exactly what they want him to do I
mean it's just you know they they don't
want to throw the ball 40 times a game
and he's always going to be good for an
interception I mean that's just that's
who you get but he hasn't gotten in the
way of what has been a very successful
formula which is his job is to turn
around and hand it off to one of three
or four guys occasionally throw the ball
and then go sit and watch the defense
prevent him from having to play under
stress he's he hasn't been so much a
game manager
as a guy who's basically been given sort
of a short list of to dues on on a
Sunday and he's met them all so worship
confidence with him he's sort of
ancillary to the core of this team which
is running and defending ray it's good
to talk to you as always and we
appreciate your time I've missed you
terribly
I almost believe you Ray I almost
believe you I almost believe me yes
that's ray Ratto Bay Area's sportswriter
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on be our live or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]